okay check this out ready I'm just
kidding this isn't that kind of ring how
to describe this kind of ring it's the
one ring to rule the no it's not I liked
it so I put a ring no it's not that
either with this ring I thee know it's
none of those everybody who makes these
calls them smart rings I guess that's
good enough there are a lot of different
kinds of smart rings out there some try
to be jewelry first in the technology
second a few are weld they're hideous
but they have so much tech power and
some like this one try to be somewhere
in the middle this is called vinaya and
it's actually one of the coolest smart
rings out there the companies mostly
selling it to people who travel a lot
and give presentations since you can use
the little touchpad to swipe through
PowerPoint slides but it can also invoke
Siri or control your music or use the
little light to alert you when you have
important notifications it's not
something you're meant to wear all the
time none of these rings really are we
can be surprised how often it's handy to
just be able to change the song or
scroll through Netflix queues and even
that's on the complicated side of things
this one's called the NFC ring and it's
basically just an NFC reader you can use
it to swap information with somebody or
unlock your phone maybe pay for the
Train things like that I kind of love
this thing it's so small and so simple
and once you get used to wearing a ring
it really just feels like part of you
smart rings are the smallest simplest
wearables that we have right now and
everybody's trying to figure out what to
do with them or even if they're a good
idea at all but I can promise you one
thing you won't have to travel up a live
volcano and throw this ring into the
fire in order to save the universe
actually I can't promise that but I
think you're safe